how do you find your passion I find that
many are scared of their passion AKA
their interests their Hobbies skiing
Legos cooking video games people don't
think their interest is a business
Dustin's interest in BMX by culture I
don't believe he thought that that was a
business that he could make 150k a year
being in the BMX business if you didn't
understand that he could do a daily
podcast or do videos or be a hoodie
maker of BMX culture and make 100K a
year that is real my big thing is if
you're 18 to 29 try it because you won't
have to regret not trying it all right
so you clearly have many passionate Die
Hard fans that care about you on a
really deep emotional level and they're
willing to travel across across the
country and pay thousand dollars for you
so my question is what are some
practical concrete steps that a content
creator or a company can take to have an
audience care about care about them on
an emotional level and therefore care
about their words products and services
that they offer it's a great question
brother two things one I love your shirt
two
um
the answer is the way you get people to
love something is by you loving them
first
for a human to get love one of the at
scale I think it's predicated on them
loving first for me
one of the great reasons I think
everything happened was my intent was to
provide value like I was like I'm good I
know how to be happy without people's
money love attention you know I'm good
so this allows me to be like remarkably
generous emotionally and strategically I
don't think you can really create
something of scale as a content creator
without providing outrageous levels of
value value comes in a lot of different
forms but I think the thing that's been
a little bit different about my world is
unlike a music artist or an athlete or
someone who's like funny or attractive
or an actor like I'm on a daily basis
trying to give people either emotional
or tactical things that bring them value
and I did that for a decade before any
of you knew who the [__] I was like I
did it every day
every day every day and you know in 2010
it was a couple of hundred people and in
2023 it's a lot more so I think the
answer it's kind of like parenting and
all of you are too young for that at
this point but like they're gonna love
you as much as you love them first and I
think the reason a lot of people
struggle as content creators is all
about them how many likes am I gonna get
how much money am I gonna make out of
this how many hoodies can I sell to them
how many courses can I sell to them it's
all selfish and the reality is it's all
about being selfless and so I think
that's the answer to your question my
guy
that hoodie I love it even better I'll
send it to you
and clearly it's like it can like it's
called yes a lot yes so do you still
think it's the future or like are you
buying low or are you like out loud I
don't know if you caught this but most
of my summer and fall last year was
saying that 99 of them were going to go
to zero because I believe in the macro
but I saw all the green and the
short-term Behavior so I knew it was
going to be a problem it's kind of like
the difference of believing that stuffed
animals are going to be something that
everyone's gonna be into as Kids versus
beanie babies right so too much of the
behavior was beanie babies and
speculation but I believe in nfts and
web 3 the most because it's a macro
technology I'll give you the comp
the way you said that Gary you believed
in nfts that would be like you saying
Gary you believed in iPhone apps but 99
of the iPhone apps in the first two
years have failed and I'll be like yeah
that's exactly right but I still think
Instagram and Uber and Waze are coming
and that's how I think about nfts right
I I know that a lot of projects failed
because a lot of people came in with
greed they were selfish like we just
talked about but there will be one
percent that are good now and people
will learn from this last year and
people will build meaningful things
going forward you always say like in
your 20s and 30s you gotta like
experiment and go explore yes how to do
the same thing I uh you know came to the
states when I was 17 studied really hard
as an immigrant like being Korean uh and
did a quick Stanford in my grad school
for Environmental Studies made my
parents really happy but then I realized
I never really risked
um doing something that I truly felt
passionate about because I was afraid of
failing it at it but also I was afraid
of um
my Paris
disappointing parents especially
immigrant parents in a U.S environment
is is one of the biggest things I focus
on because I got so fortunate because I
was an immigrant but my mother gave me
the freedom to be myself and it led to
so much good both emotional and
professional success but you know
that is just a very rare story to this
day
parents India Asia Europe I mean Africa
I mean it is it is the great disservice
that parents are doing to their children
and they don't realize that they think
they're helping and so it comes from a
good place but it is created oh sure a
lot of Voters I mean they work their ass
off and but then when I went to Stanford
like I think I did enough for them and
then I started following my passion in
art and running I love this I've been
running and I went to Kenya so I could
leave it wrong with it was just amazing
um see if that's kind of my story it's
very similar you know similar to mine
right I yeah I didn't do it through
school I did it through I need I want to
give back to my parents by building
their business yeah and then at 34 went
and did my thing no I love that I love
that you did that were your did your
parents struggle in that transition when
you were ready to do something for
yourself or were they fulfilled the yeah
that's the other thing it's like the
other thing I'm thinking a lot about is
like all right I went to the Ivy League
school but let me live my life and it's
like where do parents
they really need to find their you know
their way in letting their kids live
their lives which is really interesting
because when I speak to the parents
which it happens multiple times a year
that are doing this to the children
their parents did it to them
right exactly which is which to me is
almost the most inappropriate because
you you know that you were so unhappy
about this why are you do like it's a
it's hypocrisy at its best you were mad
at your parents and now you're doing it
to your kids that's a level of like lack
of Consciousness time yeah that's the
play but they really believe they would
work for me I know that for me so like
it was very interesting conversation
with them they would ask me like why
would you not work at like Google or
Facebook where your friends work at like
make six figures and whatnot and I've
been making like 20 to 40K a year which
is really not much compared to what my
friends are making people I'm just so
happy and when I made a decision to go
into running I was like I'm just gonna
[__] live in Kenya I don't I don't
remember [__] and and what the world
hasn't figured out yet is living within
one's means is the only thing one needs
to do to eliminate the anxiety
associated with their fee the amount of
people I know that make 283 000 a year
and stress about money every day is
staggering it's because they live at 413
000 lifestyle if you make 39 000 a year
and you live a twenty three thousand
dollar lifestyle
You've Won especially if you're happy
and by the way I say this from a place
of knowledge I yeah you know I me I I in
every year of my twenties post school
did not make a hundred thousand dollars
a year and when I was from 45 to 55 to
65 because my dad didn't pay me that
much I lived within those means and had
savings I just I got fortunate or
unfortunate that I worked every minute I
didn't have the weekend to spend money
on I never wanted to impress anyone so I
didn't need to buy anything to impress
everyone's vulnerabilities they're
trying to impress someone with the
things they buy which makes them buy
things they don't need I am still doing
full-time marketing right now
um two years ago I did like organic
social medias when I started I remember
last year and I talked to you one client
now I have five so I am excited but um
I've been posting more on LinkedIn Tick
Tock and I've been sitting out recent
probably over like 150 cold emails like
a 30 open rate but like really not that
many people says hi it is good it's very
high really okay 30 open rate
yeah and then what
nothing yeah crickets what are you
emailing them
um just like information that like I saw
their stuff I thought they'd be a good
fit this is my website you're going in
too hard what you need to do is send an
email and say hey
uh I would title it 90 minute
Karma
90 minute Karma driven free social media
q a seminar
I'll say it again nice and slow because
I want to make sure you get it titled 90
minute Karma driven
free seminar q a with me in there you go
hey love your stuff I'm just very good
at my craft and social media content
I like providing people value no strings
attached here's the Google Hangout link
April 17th from 4 to 5 30. please come
if you want to come and I'm just going
to talk of the State of the Union of
social media as it continues to become
important
if you have one person show up
phenomenal if you have 23 phenomenal and
literally you go there and you give them
the best information you can give them
pro bono and that will convert into
clients and if it doesn't you still
created Karma which always is a good
thing right
the reason you're getting very good open
rates you're not getting conversions
because you're trying to sell
yeah right right right
back okay yeah well another thing is
we've kind of been so right now like I
said when you do organic social media
for my clients
um with some other marketing things too
I do like I've done like branded photo
shoots gotta coordinate for some of them
um
um I'll do like marketing collateral
just miscellaneous just to add value I
don't add that into a price right now
it's just more in their monthly retainer
so just show them like I appreciate you
here's some extra work that you need
help with I can do no extra charge
um but then like my some clients even
after a year long they love me but they
also are like where's the true direct
return on investment and your answer is
I do brand
brand is not measurable if you want
Direct
results you need to spend media dollars
against ads I do brand and you do the
end and some people believe in I believe
in brand more than anything in the world
me too yeah a lot of small businesses
and people don't have that patience and
don't believe in it that's okay
yeah you just need to find the ones that
do right the other thing you can do is
if you see a high turn rate
you can create a Consulting product
instead of a retainer client
so the good news is you've had six
clients from day one you've lost one and
it was just because it was just because
it was like
if that happens friends yeah that's
don't even spend no time thinking about
who you lost think about all your time
of how to get better and find new people
we interrupt this program to bring you a
special report
how do you want your passion I'm in my
Discord right now and this is something
people ask me all the time and I find
that many are scared of their passion
AKA their interests their Hobbies um
skiing Legos cooking video games people
don't think their interest is a business
Dustin's interest in BMX by culture I
don't believe he thought that that was a
business that he could make 150k a year
being in the BMX business but he didn't
understand that he could do a daily
podcast or do videos or be a hoodie
maker of BMX culture and make 100K a
year that is real my big thing is if
you're 18 to 29 try it because you won't
have to regret not trying it someone
just asked me what kind of content what
what kind of content do you find does
the best my answer in my Discord was the
one that comes from the heart or the one
that comes from the brain you were
either winning on emotional truths or
intellectual truths things that you
really [__] believe in or have real
passion for or [__] that you really know
so much of what garyvee has won on in my
opinion is that the [__] I love is the
[__] I know and I've got both but when I
break off into you know maybe I'm less
passionate about it but I'm speaking to
it or I'm passionate and it's more like
sports stuff or blueberries or stuff of
that and I don't know as much about it
those work so for me great content comes
from the heart or the brain tips for a
college student who wants to drop out
the answer to that is to drop out if you
want to drop out you should drop out if
you're not dropping out because of the
stigma that's already gone nobody gives
a [__] no I don't even know who any I
don't know a single employees College if
you told me right now tell me what
college Dustin Katie or Nick Anderson
went to I would lose I go for three and
so you should drop out because that's
where your heart is that's where your
mind is but let there be no confusion
whether you go through college or you
drop out to actually win in the real
world is going to take real effort real
work ethic real talent really honing
your skills like this is all real work
out here a lot of people get confused
because they're good at school and that
doesn't work and a lot of people get
confused of like I'm gonna drop out [__]
it I don't need school but your lazy ass
is gonna win in the real world either
you better change that [__] energy if
you're lazy as [__] school like I was
you better flip that [__] energy when
you go into the real world yeah a quick
refresher so I run a company called
American canning where
basically a beverage can an equipment
supplier to small and scaling beverage
brands I think last time we talked I we
were talking about building our own cane
manufacturing plant
while last year we actually did that
totally different than any other plant
here one is we use the Japanese
technology they've been doing it for 22
years it's the most environmentally
friendly canned plant in the world and
two
it uses different technology that's
basically
increasing the shelf life substantially
for like products like wine spirits
based rtds cider more acidic stuff
Gallows started importing and using
these cans on all their Dark Horse
initially and they use it on everything
now so we built a plant in the U.S first
that's awesome that's [__] awesome I
mean I guess just some insights from you
or hot takes on where's the beverage
Market going that premiumization trend
is happening in categories that are
tough to you know holding cans for long
term but you know how would you kind of
approach getting a word out there
driving adoption content platforms all
that good stuff you know I think it's
it's education comes in the form of
communication
right like so unlimited podcasts
unlimited infographics unlimited
um in you interviewing people that
actually know the truth unlimited you
making one two minute hot takes why
just unlimited like again it's so easy
and so hard like the things I believe in
if I own this business I would do what I
did with Wine Library TV I make a video
every day for five years and then [__]
would start happening
right and you know that's hard to say
because people don't have the time they
think but it's it's similar to I used to
literally think I didn't have time to
work out I'm busier than ever and I have
time to work out I prioritized most
people are not prioritizing content
creation without realizing it is the
oxygen of their growth people think
social media content is like some nice
little nice to have or tier six to my
real business your real [__] business
is to communicate your business
for sure
I mean what what because this would be
obviously right so like I mean platform
wise I mean LinkedIn very hot LinkedIn
but be
for B to C to
if you go crazy and do a tick tock thing
of like like if you became the guy that
says demand your favorite beverage to
use this technology and like every time
at the end could be like let's all go
attack Bud Light here's the LinkedIn to
the Bud Light brand manager on LinkedIn
like you could create a whole viral
movement do you think consumers give a
[__] I mean yeah it's a commodity no no
I think consumers give real shits now I
think 10 years ago consumers gave no
shits 20 years ago consumers gave no
shits now better whether that's
healthier better for the environment
better for you better for it to be
stable but go to the consumer side that
then says then you create a website that
has like 80 of your if you came out and
said 80 of our favorite brands that we
would love to see our cans and you have
a [__] logo of like whatever brand
and then I literally a URL to the
LinkedIn
oh of the brand manager of Dr Pepper or
[__] Corona whatever [__] you could
create a whole swell because at the end
of your Tick Tock you're like by the way
link to link to the people that can help
you make this a reality in our bio okay
yeah and you know Corona and Dr Pepper
they're too big to maybe give a [__] but
if you find some small mid-sized brands
that are like would be iconic customers
for you if they switched over in that
sweet middle that'd be epic so I want to
ask if you have any advice for starting
entrepreneurs you're just like also
reading either time to like develop into
their own that's it gonna start their uh
entrepreneurial journey and then
probably one of the most difficult
environments that they're thin like
they're less ethic right yeah but
honestly it's not that difficult meaning
it's to your point it's been one of the
more difficult ones in the last decade
because the last decade's been [__]
Fantasyland
but the economy right now is much
stronger than it was in 2008 and nine
it's much stronger than it was in the
late 90s like you know like it's much
stronger so yeah you don't want to get
caught in the delusion of like what's
happening which is everyone's lost
context of a 50-year window
like yes if you compare it to four years
ago it's harder but yeah it's way easier
than it was in 2008 and nine it got real
bad
like people are losing job like people
are unemployed
yeah right now people are just dealing
with inflation but that's more talk
that's almost more just people aren't
capable of managing their own money
yeah you know what I mean it's not like
you don't have a job it's just that you
continue to have four streaming services
when you're living paycheck to paycheck
and maybe two would be okay like Netflix
and Hulu is okay
you don't need [__] HBO Max
yeah
into perspective yeah so that's the
reason that's good is now you're like
okay wait a minute because now it's like
even though you're like I'm up for the
challenge it's like oh [__] it's tough
It's not really tough like it's actually
[__] I would actually argue it's way
easier with the way social media is what
they weigh information is like it's
never been easier to be an entrepreneur
even in this softened economy
yeah because the ease of the tools and
the costs associated with the
opportunity are outpacing
the
difficultness in the market
yeah that makes a lot of sense that what
is something that um
most people in this this day and age is
like kind of belong to something like
something that you're seeing that's
obvious to you but that other people are
just not seeing at the moment
that people's entitlement is destroying
their happiness I just don't understand
how we got into this place where
everyone thinks everyone owes them
something that's true and I when you say
it and I also kind of feel guilty about
it because I know that I have some of
that as well it's by the way all of us
do
you can't be a human being without
expecting things from your parents
yeah but
boy oh boy does that lead to unhappiness
what's your take on uh you know how
everyone's expecting your crypto crash
and just generally the crypto Market
what's your take on that
I mean I think it ready corrected in a
meaningful way right things are down
quite a bit I believe you know my take I
made very public a year ago and further
back of 99 was going to go to zero
because I thought there was too much
greed but the macro is very real and I
think over the next three to five years
um blockchain technology will be a
meaningful part of our society
and how would uh are we able to see more
integration of AI into nfcs what's your
take on AI and nfts like combined I
think AI is going to be a part of
everything
it's like an oxygen technology it's a
utility to make things more efficient
so yeah I mean to me the creation of
nfts will be AI potentially the
scripts that are written for the
narrative I mean there's just so much
that ai ai is like saying computers like
we'll we'll do you know it's like it's
like 1980 and you're asking do you think
uh computers will integrate with my
pavement company I'm like yes and 40
years later we have websites for every
pavement company and people process
their Billings through a computer like
AI is just going to be Omni it's a it's
a thing it's like
course you will like it's like a tractor
or like a calculator or like a marker
anything that makes humans lives more
efficient
um we will do electricity like we will
do it and AI will make a lot of things
more efficient in our society
perfect great answer thank you uh my
last question is since we're a
meditation based project we actually do
guided live meditation on all of our
social media every weekend uh what's
meditation to you and like if you
practice is how do you practice it and
how would you how are you mindful of
things and how would you ask other
people to be mindful
I think everything I just heard is full
commitment to gratitude
I feel like I meditate every day though
I don't actively meditate the way the
world speaks about it and the way I do
that is by leaning 100 into gratitude
by being grateful for what I have versus
anxious or unhappy for what I don't have
it keeps me in a steady state of
contentness that I wish for the world
hey Gary about company culture the
culture advantage and I look at why
culture is so important to Innovation
why companies need to focus on it and
that's my message the question I have is
how do I get that message out there what
communities and where do you find people
who care about company culture
LinkedIn I think you should produce
unlimited amounts of content on LinkedIn
I do it every day I get feedback from it
every day the problem is it's not where
are they are people disciplined enough
to spend a decade making content every
day at scale and building Community
every day at scale to have a big enough
audience to find audience
I I think it is just completely
forgotten what is it 2023 I've made
content
at scale
and have engaged with people at scale I
went from 2006 to 2011 with not going to
sleep until I emailed back every person
that emailed me
I've been making content on the internet
every day at scale for 17 years
this is not where do you find the
audience what should be pumping out this
is I don't want to do it for 10 years
hard every day to get to a level that
seems cool
and cool being like financially viable
and so I think the answer is LinkedIn
the question is does one have the
bandwidth the talent the conviction and
the patience to do it at scale for 10
years to get to a level
I don't know
[Music]